veronica islas el centro de recursos
interculturales que usted preside ha
realizado una actividad que tiende a
mostrarle al público 5 lugares de culto
en la ciudad de montreal o en quebec en
general de qué se trata esta idea
y nosotros de lo que nos damos cuenta es
de que hay mucha falta de conocimiento
sobre tanto es una de las comunidades
culturales como sobre los lugares de
culto que esas comunidades pueden
frecuentar
y las personas tienden a pensar que son
muy diferentes son muy lejanos de lo que
ellos conocen y entonces éste está esta
visita de los lugares de culto decidimos
hacerla para demostrar a las personas
que finalmente las raíces o los
fundamentos de cada una de estas de
estos cultos son muy parecidos las
personas buscan mucho el respeto del uno
al otro
el respeto y el amor hacia los demás
hacia la vida entonces algunos de
fundamentos profundos que son muy
similares a pesar de que pudiéramos
llegar a pensar
que las creencias o las religiones son
diferentes y entonces lo que buscábamos
hacer un poco demostrar eso y demostrar
que todo eso que habita muy bien desde
hace mucho tiempo y que a veces se crean
controversias que no lo son porque
realmente eso existe desde hace mucho
tiempo y cohabita muy bien y como
ejemplo está el suntrust dónde empezamos
esta actividad en el desarrollo de moral
que es el autismo de vilmarie y nos
dimos cuenta que realmente esto
funcionaba muy bien están varios templos
y lugares de culto y las personas los de
costumbre en el que es una plática gary
y se dan cuenta de que todos son
fabulosos y terminan diciendo guau guau
sabía todo esto y es muy interesante
entonces este funciona muy bien la
verdad y ahora con el móvil decidimos
hacerlo un poco más a la escala de todo
montreal y éste ya sale un vídeo para
que más personas puedan descubrir esta
actividad porque normalmente este como
es un poco local la descubre pocas
personas ahora la descuidan las personas
y pasa que uno de los lugares del punto
que visitamos fue la misión de este
católica de latinoamericanas de
guadalupe que está en el maguey y que de
hecho reagrupa muchísimas comunidades
porque hablamos de latinoamericanos pero
chinos son los latinoamericanos son
personas de sudamérica de centroamérica
y de norteamérica si consideramos méxico
entonces esté aún ahí hay muchísima
riqueza cultural y lo que buscábamos
meter en valor esa diversidad que trae
mucha riqueza y que trae muchos valores
profundos que compartimos con la
comunidad
y en este año de pandemia verónica como
usted decía la visita presencial el
contacto físico es más complicado
entonces lo que ustedes han hecho es
preparar vídeos mostrando esos lugares
la vida interior facetas desconocidas de
hecho la información que ustedes han
repartido promoviendo otra actividad
habla de eso de facetas desconocidas de
estos centros de estos lugares porque
muchas personas ni siquiera saben este
que esos lugares existen desde hace
muchísimo tiempo que tienen todo un
traje en sus comunidades y que tienen
servicios que van mucho más allá de los
lugares de culto o de la cuestión
religiosa la mayoría de los lugares de
culto ofrecen servicios a la comunidad y
ofrecen los servicios de la comunidad
aunque no sea su comunidad religiosa
otra vez lo van a regresar con la misión
de guadalupe es un buen ejemplo
ellos tienen este lo que aquí le dicen
de panal y magda que es ayuda
alimenticia china y este y éste le
ofrecen a todas
nosotros hemos tenido personas de
muchísimas confesiones que hemos
acompañado y que hemos referido ahí a
pesar de que no son católicos cristianos
porque esa parroquia está abierta a
ofrecer el servicio a personas de
cualquier confesión porque lo que les
interesa es también apoyar a una
colectividad y todas esas son facetas
desconocidas de todos estos lugares de
culto que cuando las personas descubren
disney finalmente son muy abiertos y nos
gustaría a nosotros también abrirlos
entonces es como que facilitar también
esa cohabitación crecemos un poco eso de
entre más conoce uno más este está
abierto a cohabitar ya descubrir y
aparte los vídeos nos permiten también
descubrir un lado humano de los líderes
de estas estero de esos lugares de culto
que también es este extraordinario que
son oficiosos simpáticos que son este
son un poco como que por aquí entonces
éste también eso trae una riqueza
videos esta actividad se enmarca en lo
que ustedes han denominado la semana
quebequense de encuentros
interculturales de qué se trata esta
semana y cuál es la actividad que van a
llevar a cabo
y bueno hablar la semana de encuentros
qué piensas de encuentros
interculturales comenzó el 19 de octubre
y está toda la semana va a ir hasta el
domingo el domingo es este
permítanme el domingo es el 25 y de
hecho lo que busque esa semana esto está
organizada por el ministerio de
invitación y de la francesa ción y de la
integración y unión que ve aquí lo que
busca es éste precisamente facilitar el
diálogo entre diferentes culturas entre
la cultura
la acogida de la sociedad quebequense y
diferentes culturas entonces crear
fuentes crear un diálogo
a buscar maneras de comunicarnos mejor
de descubrir a otras culturas y
descubrir cómo éstas pueden influenciar
nos y enriquecernos como como sociedad
de una manera más grande y este y en ese
sentido la actividad de las visitas a
los lugares de culto
entra perfecta porque es una manera de
crear un diálogo interno entre creencias
y de inter culturas en la que es
convocar un poco permitir a una persona
desde afuera de ver algo que normalmente
no tiene la ocasión de ver y descubrirlo
con una nueva mirada y de los lugares de
culto pues es un súper buen ejemplo
luego vino una visita a un templo si
hubo una visita a una mezquita hubo una
visita a una iglesia anglicana hubo una
visita a la misión
católica latinoamericana y hubo una
visita a un templo judío de sinagoga que
tiene de hecho a una mujer como como
rápida y bastante externa y entonces ahí
nos va rompiendo varios prejuicios que
podríamos tener sobre diferentes este
sobre diferentes religiones ya saber que
las gamas adentro también son muy
variables que pueden más allá de lo que
podríamos pensar la entrada cuando no lo
vemos despierta aún por último veronica
hablando con una hispanohablante no se
puede dejar de recordar de señalar que
estamos en el mes de la herencia hispana
que se celebra aquí en quebec y también
en otras provincias en el resto de
canadá qué valor tiene para usted este
mes y cuál es en todo caso para usted la
herencia más importante que los hispanos
aportan a la comunidad quebequense
canadiense en general
y mira pues para eso es tan importante
para para
nuestra sociedad de actualidad que es
reconocida por los tres niveles de
gobierno está reconocida por el gobierno
de canadá por el gobierno de quebec y
también está reconocida por el gobierno
de la ciudad de montreal porque porque
es una comunidad muy grande es una
comunidad como elegimos un poquito antes
es muy diversa
cuando hablamos también de eres hispana
hablamos de muchas culturas que traen
mucha solidaridad que traen
a una riqueza e incluso autóctona de
extraordinaria en nuestras tierras hay
muchísima variedad de riqueza autóctona
en riqueza culinaria riqueza literaria
riqueza artística hay artistas fabulosos
latinoamericanos y todo eso viene a
influenciar a la
la cultura de aquí y hacerla mejor
hacerla más sólida entonces es por eso
es que se celebra el mes de la herencia
hispana y de hecho nuestra organización
va a animar un taller el día 30 de
octubre un taller este culinario de
comida mexicana va a ser un taller para
que las personas puedan descubrir la
comida mexicana y poder cocinarla de sus
casas porque sobre todo cuando hace frío
como que algo así este que nos pueda
recordar también a casa nos cae nos cae
calientito tanto en el estómago como en
el corazón y en el alma no entonces éste
pues es una herencia muy importante y
estamos muy contentos de que el gobierno
de quebec y de canadá lo reconozca
porque hace no tanto tiempo el gobierno
de nada de demostrar lleva apenas tres
años reconociendo esto y el gobierno de
quebec creo que 4 o 5 o sea que es algo
reproductivamente reciente para nuestra
comunidad lleva muchísimos años aquí
instalando piedras picando piedras para
crear para crear un futuro y para para
para precisamente venir a enriquecer la
cultura de acogida cuando la esa riqueza
cultural queremos y para cerrar nuestro
diálogo precisamente en ese largo
proceso de picar piedras para tallar un
camino para abrir un camino cuál es el
principal desafío que la comunidad
hispana debe asumir en este momento
yo creo que el desafío de la comunidad
hispana va a ser realmente estar bien
informados sobre todos los cambios
porque en este momento con la pandemia
tenemos que estar super bien informado
la información cambia de un día a otro y
tenemos que estar realmente muy bien
informados
este es yo creo que tenemos que seguir
todos los lineamientos del gobierno y
estar informados sobre todo los
servicios que se pueden abrir para para
los inmigrantes para todos los hispanos
porque es donde hay este tragedia
también hay oportunidad y las personas
tal vez este están englobados en la
tragedia que que no vemos que también
hay muchas oportunidades ahorita están
habiendo muchos apoyos económicos para
abrir empresas para para rehacer nuestra
vida y como inmigrantes somos super
resilientes y siempre buscamos la manera
los latinoamericanos somos
las personas muy distante poco ya no
buscamos la manera de hacer las cosas de
reinventarnos y en este momento también
está esa posibilidad de entonces de
informarse quién pueden contactar a
organizaciones como el clic para ver qué
posibilidades hay para ellos porque así
éste hay muchos apoyos del gobierno en
este momento para empresas para personas
a trabajadoras autónomas para
trabajadores que perdieron sus empleos
pero también está en otras áreas que se
están abriendo entonces es mantenerse
informados y este y quedarse quedarse de
manera saludable asegurarse que su salud
esté quede integrado porque también como
latinoamericanos a veces podemos tener
este por ejemplo más riesgo de diabetes
que las personas
nativa de aquí entonces este este tipo
de cosas tenemos que tener cuidado
respecto a la salud y el cobismo
veronica islas del centro de recursos
interculturales muchas gracias por esta
entrevista con radio que nos daba
internacional y suerte en esta semana
muchas gracias a ustedes y buen día y
pondría ahorita